[Musique]
contact marc uhry nous coûter à côté de
bâtiments plutôt austère ce potager
occupent les élèves du programme eau
environnement et agriculture urbaine
c'est pas moi qui a choisi serre par an
est finalement comment papa ça soit ce
bief est cool moi je ne savais pas que
je m'embarquais là dedans et une fois
dans le mood c'était bien la partie
pratique semble plaire aux élèves de
deuxième secondaire ils ont dit on va
plutôt sortir dehors allez prendre leur
faire pousser les légumes et tout ça ils
ont dit que le cours d'agriculture
c'était nouveau mais j'ai dit que je
voulais essayer je me suis dit que ça
pouvait changer de faire que des maths
c'est la deuxième année que l'école
louis joseph papineau offre ce programme
comme d'autres offres du sport études je
suis content parce que ça nous apprend
ça nous sensibilise sur la question
environnementale
eh ben c'est le fun aussi de sortir il
le cultive et on a failli le jardin on
peut ramener des affaires chez nous
qu'on a fait nous même pas un industriel
et ça c'est sûrement nancy
ces jardins que se partagent plusieurs
organismes communautaires du quartier
saint-michel abrite aussi les parcelles
cultivées par les élèves à quoi ça sert
c'est comme un petit radware tu as
raison tu as parfaitement raison ils
sont guidés par une enseignante de
l'école des métiers de l'horticulture de
montréal sont en équipe de deux par
parcelle
et oui ils doivent s'en occuper depuis
la préparation le smi le désherbage
l'entretien et ensuite les résultats
sont évalués à la fin de l'année
scolaire est-ce que je peux patiner en
faire non pour celle qui enseigne
l'aspect théorique du programme il faut
cultiver la conscience environnementale
des jeunes est important de sensibiliser
les jeunes à leur environnement
qu'est-ce que tu laisses comme
empruntent au calme et on achète une
bouteille de plastique qu'est ce que
devient que vous allez rire c'est pour
ceux que le programme est important
comme une petite graine pour la tomate
on plante une petite graine dans leur
cerveau au niveau environnement
agriculture urbaine pis ça fait des
petits les enjeux écologiques sont
peut-être plus présent qu'avant et
l'agriculture urbaine plus tendances
cette école secondaire a décidé de leur
faire une place de choix l'agriculture
urbaine l'écologie l'environnement c'est
tendance donc même si le premier jour de
classe c'est pas évident pour tout le
monde que on est dans un programme qui
est cool je pense qu'avec le temps ils
vont s'apercevoir qu'ils étaient en
avant-garde je vienne ramener duquel et
du piment on va finir la récolte
comment on récolte le chou frisé c'est
quelque chose qui fascine plus d'un
parce qu'ils aiment ça donc qu'ils ont
chacun leurs légumes de prédilection des
légumes qu'ils vont utiliser davantage
dans leur cuisine avec dans leur famille
et en commençant avec la récolte les
jeunes voient le fruit des efforts qu'il
faudra investir en planification et en
préparation
pour tous le potager soit encore
généreux l'année suivante ici anne
louise despatie radio-canada à montréal
[Musique]